Por siglos,
la gente ha consumido insectos,
de todo desde escarabajos
a gusanos,
langostas,
saltamontes,
termitas
y libélulas.
La práctica incluso
tiene un nombre:
entomofagia.
Los cazadores recolectores de
la antigüedad quizá aprendieron
de los animales de forraje
que comían insectos
ricos en proteínas
y siguieron el ejemplo.
Conforme evolucionamos
los insectos se volvieron parte
de nuestra tradición dietética,
cumplieron el rol
tanto de alimento básico
como de manjar.
En la Grecia antigua,
se consideraba las cicadas
refrigerios de lujo.
Incluso a los romanos
la larva de escarabajo
les parecía una delicia.
¿Por qué perdimos
nuestro gusto por los insectos?
La razón de nuestro
rechazo es histórico
y la historia probablemente comenzó
alrededor del año 10 mil a.C.
en el Creciente Fértil,
un lugar de Medio Oriente
que fue el principal lugar de
nacimiento de la agricultura.
En aquel entonces, nuestro
ancestros alguna vez nómadas,
empezaron a establecerse
en el Creciente.
Al ir aprendiendo a
cosechar cultivos
y domesticar animales,
las actitudes cambiaron,
extendiendo su dominio
hacia Europa
y al resto del mundo.
Cuando el cultivo despuntó,
la gente quizá desdeño
los insectos como mera peste
que destruía sus cultivos.
Las poblaciones crecieron
y Occidente comenzó
a urbanizarse,
debilitando las conexiones de
nuestro pasado de forrajeo.
La gente simplemente se olvidó
de su historia rica de insectos.
Hoy, para la gente no
acostumbrada a la entomofagia,
los insectos son un factor irritante.
Pican y muerden,
e infestan nuestra comida.
Los asociamos con
un "factor de repulsión"
y nos desagrada
la idea de
cocinar insectos.
Casi 2 000 especies de insectos
se convierten en alimento,
que forma gran parte
de la dieta diaria
para 2 000 millones de
personas en el mundo.
Los países de los trópicos son
los consumidores más entusiastas
porque culturalmente
se acepta.
Además las especies en
esas regiones son grandes,
diversas
y tienden a congregarse
en grupos o enjambres
lo que facilita su cosecha.
Como en Camboya
al sureste asiático
donde se recolectan
gigantescas tarántulas
se fríen
y se venden en los mercados.
Al sur de África,
la jugosa oruga mopane
es un alimento básico
que se cocina lentamente
en una salsa picante
o se comen seca y salada.
Y en México,
los chapulines picados
tostados con ajo,
limón y sal.
Los insectos se pueden comer
enteros y hacer una comida con ellos
o molidos en harina, polvo y pasta
que se agrega a la comida.
Pero no se trata del sabor.
Son también sanos.
De hecho, los científicos
dicen que la entomofagia
puede ser una solución
de costo efectivo
para los países en desarrollo
que tienen inseguridad alimentaria.
Los insectos pueden contener
hasta un 80% de proteína,
los componentes vitales del cuerpo,
y también tienen alto contenido
de grasas ricas en energía
fibras,
y micronutrientes como
vitaminas y minerales.
¿Sabías que la mayoría de
los insectos comestibles
contienen la misma cantidad
o incluso más hierro mineral
que la carne de vaca,
convirtiéndolos en una enorme
fuente sin explotar
¿Sabes que la deficiencia de hierro
es actualmente el problema
de nutrición más común
del mundo?
El gusano de la harina
es otro ejemplo nutritivo.
La larva del escarabajo amarillo
es nativa de los EEUU
y fácil de criar.
Tienen alto contenido vitamínico,
montones de minerales sanos
y puede contener hasta
un 50% de proteína,
casi tanto como en una cantidad
equivalente de carne de res.
Para cocinarlo, simplemente se pone
mantequilla y sal en la sartén
se tuesta y espolvorea
con chocolate
para un refrigerio crujiente.
Lo que tienes que vencer
con el "factor de repulsión",
lo ganas en nutrición
y sabor.
En efecto, los insectos
pueden ser deliciosos.
Los gusanos de la harina saben
a nueces tostadas.
Las langostas a camarón.
Los grillos, como dicen algunos,
tienen un aroma de
palomitas de maíz
Cultivas insectos para alimento
tienen también menos
impacto ambiental
que la crianza de ganado
porque los insectos emiten mucho
menos gases de efecto invernadero
y usan mucho menos
espacio, agua y alimento.
Socioeconómicamente,
la producción de insectos
podría sustentar a la gente
de países en desarrollo
dado que la crianza de insectos
se puede hacer a escala pequeña,
altamente productiva
y aun así relativamente
barata de mantener.
Los insectos también
se pueden convertir en
alimento más sustentable
para el ganado
y puede recolectarse
del despedicio orgánico,
como las cáscaras vegetales,
que de otra forma quizá terminarían
pudriéndose en vertederos.
¿Ya tienes hambre?
Ante un plato de grillos fritos,
la mayoría hoy
todavía se echaría atrás,
al imaginarse todas
esas patas y antenas
atorarse entre los dientes.
Pero piensen en una langosta,
es muy parecida a
un insecto gigante
repleto de patas y antenas
que alguna vez fue considerado
alimento repulsivo e inferior.
Ahora la langosta
es un manjar.
¿Puede ocurrir el mismo cambio
de paradigma para los insectos?
¡Hagan la prueba!
Pongan ese insecto en la boca
y disfruten el crujido.